[Music]
special projects Nicole the turkey leg
is in the cello case what do you make of
that you reached chubby Chucky say it in
code
okay wait the Cougar lies with Spanish
moss yeah that means Khrushchev's been
assassinated I haven't memorized the
code book so you reached chubby Chucky
that's awesome did anyone in the North
Korean government make you I never set
foot in North Korea amazing but you
definitely made contact with chubby
Chucky absolutely I told him we thought
a debilitating North Korean computer
virus that brought our country to its
knees would be rude I played on a sense
of decorum and he agreed to scrap stacks
not just like that just like that you
still don't get it do you winters i
coaxed him i massaged him you hack into
computers but I hack into hearts and
minds but they'll probably cut his
rations so he also wants 20 million
dollars worth of D branded fudgesicles
we can do that and he also wants access
to every American's voicemail messages
what why well he's been in Pyongyang for
decades I think he just misses American
chitchat I guess North Korean chitchat
must be pretty depressing
nobody chit chats like Americans
chitchat nice weather today don't you
think how can we be sure the stacks met
virus is dead
Chucky said he'd send us the scrubber
code after he's heard 10 hours of
American conversations about Kim
Kardashian well I'll tell the telecoms
to share all voicemail messages with him
shouldn't be a problem
good job special agent Apple I think
there's a Presidential Medal of Freedom
in your future you know what I already
have one of those for inventing the
wu-tang clan I'm holding out for those
steak knives well I should get back to
work the NSA just sent me 10,000 brunch
instagrams to review Godspeed You agent
beep boop
Chucky's it's me toppy yeah fine it
worked
thanks again I owe you yeah yeah I know
fudge school some voicemails you'll get
them but I mean in a metaphorical sense
all right
anyway give supreme leader my best yeah
yeah yeah I know I'll tell Beyonce you
say hi what
of course he's Illuminati it's her eye
on top of the pyramid has been forever I
don't know I guess she'd be about 10,000
years old just like me
[Music]